hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am Jerry
today June 1up box arcade theme don't
know what's in it
got my male co-host here with me right
now he is going to unbox this for me and
hand me each item damn I really oh yeah
so he can be jealous and maybe I'll give
him something who knows oh yeah it's
like a I'm gonna make a small incision
on the seal here just don't let me see
what it is I don't want I will hand it
to me very smallest to biggest I'm gonna
keep this a mystery from everyone
including the onions yeah oh [ __ ] oh you
won't believe what's in here there's an
entire arcade in here I want to look you
just peaked I can't see all right check
this out here we go we're gonna start
small there's a lanyard Oh a bit of a
lanyard there
insert coin got some got some like Space
Invader a different little does look
like pac-man monsters yeah insert coin
here cool alright hey when I go to Comic
Con I can wear this thing around my neck
and be like oh lucky dog let's see what
else do we got here what else do we got
here we have a street fighter for
bobblehead that Zangief Zangief whoo
yeah I thought this was Arnold
Schwarzenegger for the first four years
of my life but that is not Arnold
Schwarzenegger this is actually a
Russian wrestler uh let's get a lot of
heat for not knowing yes I know all my
other collections from one out box this
is so cool
next we have this cool it might be like
a sticker thing it's a it's a little
arcade game one of those really fixed
it's um it's a sticker magnet oh it
might be a magnet I don't know it's like
an arcade ooh wait hold on you figure
out this is a magnet or not
a little plaque you think it might be
stick to you what is this maybe you'd
like to put it on your cars it is a
sticker it's like one of the metal
stickers oh yeah yeah yeah people will
know I like arcades then the [ __ ]
doesn't like that I carry your interests
yeah we have a spider-man zipper pull
it's all it's too much light you can't
really see it but you can imagine it
with your minds woohoo
you could use this I could I have so
many zippers you do I never use my
zipper you know Jerry happy birthday
Thanks there you go boy spider-man and
then you have a button a button a button
1up box June 2015 button that's actually
a nifty button okay thank you 1up box
for this button I'm jealous
then you have I believe these are in a
little pac-man arcade game case oh dude
that is so cool
very jealous of you there's always like
one item that really gets me and this is
it that is so [ __ ] cool well hold on
to your hat Ryan right because I got one
more thing to show you yeah what's that
Jerry it would be this oh [ __ ] it is a I
know that is so cool so one up so box so
right alright Oh thumbnail time
thumbnail time
I've said it before they could keep
adding as many characters as they want
to street fighter Ryu will always remain
my favorite alright that is so cool that
is so cool
fight fight revolution oh my god you
will definitely see me rocking the shirt
and videos I promise you that and then
to top it all off a piece of paper
explaining everything you just got in
the bud in case you should get lost yeah
metallic arcade decal those were the
words I was looking for and it's a
pac-man candy tin cool it was candy
inside well thanks 1up box here one work
all the money I know you got a
spider-man zipper pool did I did thanks
man you got some other [ __ ] I've given
you put these on the zipper to my pants
though just so it's like really it's
like really convenient to get out of
pants but also like really awkward to
watch me do it everybody cool why do you
have a Spider Man on your karate like
that why not because it shoots webs you
know what I mean yeah oh yeah in the
description link there's a referral like
I put down there you can go if you want
a 1up box you can go there purchase one
it's like 12 or 13 bucks a month I don't
know what yeah you think I count how
much money I spend every month no it's
it's let me down some horrible
situations I probably should yeah man if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you could
catch reasons to Geryon dank ass tubs on
this channel and follow us on facebook
instagram twitter and vine
cuz if we get enough followers we can
get product placement I am meaning more
money for me less money for you well no
benefit really yeah you don't really get
less money nothing happens to you we
could be sponsored by Salton cat
unsalted cashews Kirkland the best brand
out there amazing hot dogs at Costco I'm
just gonna get you a gift certificate to
Costco for your birthday for hotdogs
yeah yeah bummer right like only sell
this man hot dogs with certificate nice